thank you a part of speech talking about
the label government legislating
to freeze gas and electricity bills for
20 months should they win the next
election how could they do that what
impact might it have that felt rather
straight to the city drill Hill standing
by how would they implement that job
it's a very good question Kay and we
don't know the answer I'm afraid as yet
the detail has yet to be in party to
journalist but look hey this is a the
headline here is going to be a popular
one isn't it it's one all resonate 300
pounds worse off a year under the
coalition government that accuses the
coalition of failing to take on vested
interest and stand up to energy
companies has made it very clear that it
feels they're profiteering and that he
would intervene he would impose this
price cap do not clear when it would
happen would it happen post-prison well
presumably post-election nothing to stop
those companies putting prices up in the
run-up to any election and not clear
either who he will seek to benefit
whether it would be consumers across the
board whether it would be those who are
the most disadvantaged or indeed whether
he take on the interests of business
customers who of course pay energy bills
like the rest of us I think though okay
what's really striking about this
he's the tone of that speech if you
think in Labor's path to power
previously under Tony Blair there was an
effort made for the party to align
itself very much front and center with
corporate Britain with the PLC's there
and he was a party for business well Ed
Miliband's speech contained a you're a
price cap threat on energy companies who
it says were overcharging customers
he threatened to stick the boot into
construction companies who he basically
accused of not developing the land that
they're sitting on being responsible in
some way shape or form for a housing
crisis either use that land or lose it
was the message to him there are also
available
my inference but I'm in very clear
criticism of the railway companies and
also payday lenders so I mean it
Miliband speech was very interesting in
in as much as it was there were some
quite strident contra criticism about
the way in which companies in certain
sectors
are conducting themselves